[Musique]
mon dieu que ça fait bizarre de revenir
et ses annonces mais c'est la première
ville où je suis parti j'ai commencé à
étudier et peut-être que certains
d'entre vous il était aussi c'est le
lycée clemenceau à côté de la guerre
là-bas moi j'étais en classe et perd à
toi en baisse et pc donc c'est tout ce
qui est biologie chimie physique
sciences de la terre donc c'est une base
scientifique assez large qui m'a ensuite
permis de rentrer dans une grande école
qui a le nez ce de lyon en ressources de
la terre puis après j'ai fait revenir à
semer dans une note d'humour en école
polytechnique en suisse et je me suis
peu spécialisés en climatologie et
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait après ses grands
parcours scolaire j'ai vécu dans les
bois mais c'est un parcours assez
typique que beaucoup d'ici auront face à
une classe opératoire après faire une
grande école comme ici à centrale vous
ainsi d'après faire un boulot
d'ingénieurs mais je trouve que ce
chemin là il est trop contraint on va
pas voir ailleurs
est-ce que comment est ce que d'autres
personnes réussissent leur vie comme on
dit peut-être plus simplement plus
naturellement parce que les choix qu'on
avait après après le bac c'était quoi
c'était juste des cases ont coché sur un
un site en ligne
admission postbac mais j'ai cherché je
n'ai pas trouvé la petite croix nature
la ligue step a amassé chemin là en fait
on en a peur et on serait faire un
chemin qui est qu'ils aient connu ce qui
est connu et même qui est reconnu et en
fait ces schémas
enfin ces autres alternatives elles sont
peut-être mal vu parce que peut-être
trop simple trop naturelle par rapport
aux 1 pas d'être un conte d'ingénieurs
qui est censé avoir un parcours plus
plus complexe à avoir
je veux gré d'études et enfin tous ces
exemples l'âge que je vous donne c'est
vraiment quelqu'un exemple sur le
parcours scolaire
mais si vous réfléchissez un petit peu
ce soit d'autre chose de proche de vous
en fait c'est toujours pas la même chose
en fait on se conforme dans son analyse
pourquoi parce que ça nous rassure
et là je vais revenir justement au sujet
de cet édifice qui est tirs de la police
c'est briser les murs qui vous entourent
parce que des salles de cours je suis
arrivé en pleine nature dans les
pyrénées à vivre au grand air au grand
air c'était le cas parce que quand je
suis arrivé en début avril il y avait
encore il n'y avait plus d'un mètre de
neige
il faisait froid et c'est de vous
imaginez quand vous arrivez dans une
cabane comme ça tu vraiment rayssac et
dégueulasse il ya plein de détritus
partout et les crottes de souris
le toit est fluide il ya des gouttes
d'eau qui tombent kivumu les affaires la
cheminée qui fument donc ça choque même
pas et ça vous guident les yeux les
températures qui dépassent pas les 4 5
degrés en journée donc c'est comme si
vous vivez dans votre frigo ça pendant
deux mois et là je me demande qu'est ce
que je fous là on est c'est vrai pas
j'avais les faire beau parcours et
qu'est ce que vient faire dans cette
cabane perdue au milieu des pyrénées et
ça en fait c'est quelque chose qui je
suis je super assurée on à peur parce
que c'est comme j'ai tout à l'heure
c'est quelque chose dont 20 je connais
pas je pense pas qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'étudiants ont laissé donc j'arrive ici
et moi je veux un petit flashback aussi
dans nos projets en fait je montrais un
peu ce que ce que j'ai fait moi je suis
étudiant je fais la recherche en
climatologie et avant de faire un
doctorat avant de m'engager vraiment car
la science j'ai envie de vivre un peu
différemment voir ce question les airs
native dans la vie comment est ce que je
peux vivre du manioc fin d'une autre
manière
avant d'être vraiment sûr de continuer
vers vers la recherche
donc je prends quand même quelques
précautions avec mon école c'est à dire
que je prends une césure je signe un
contrat pour m'autoriser à rester
pendant un an faire à peu près ce que ce
que je veux pour tester votre mode de
vie
donc en fait après hocquaux furent des
changes de personnes que je rencontre
s'est alors je trouve une petite cabane
celle ci sur la droite il pas temps
encore et encore rénové dans les
pyrénées en ariège et j'aime beaucoup
l'endroit est en fait je demande
directement après omer cave
qui appartient la cabane ce à partir nos
villages
leur demande est ce que je peux venir et
rénover votre cabane ou bénévolement
il m'a dit oui en même temps ça ça les
arrangeait bien parce qu'un passage
éviter que leurs cabanes tombe en ruine
ça arrange et aussi le randonneur parce
que des fois il dormait dedans quand il
y avait des gros orages ce qu'il ingère
qui passe pas très loin et moi aussi
c'était mon projet ce que je voulais
savoir une expérience de la solitude
vraiment nous recentrer sur moi même à
voir aussi une certaine autonomie par
rapport à la société qui se veut donc
plus en plus dépendante et moi j'arrive
à la cabane mais une nouvelle cabane moi
je sais pas faire c'est à mon métier
moi je sais comment régler les
spectromètres de masse pour mesurer des
différences d'isotopes entre de l'ex de
avoir de l'oxygène remontée des panneaux
température il ya vingt mille ans c'est
cool franchement c'est vachement ce
stylet mais ça va pas m'aider à faire
des enduits sur les murs nous lever à
prendre différemment autres qu'en fait
que ce combat était à pied à l'école
donc je regarde avec des bouquins
comment est-ce que le j'en faisais
auparavant joueurs des chantiers
participatifs dumont avec des amis qui
me présente à peu quelques techniques
qu'ils savaient apprises et donc demain
je vais pas tout énumérer mais en fait
je veux montrer des trois trucs pas
raison que j'ai creusé de l'argile dans
le sol pour après mélangé avec de la
paille du sable de la chaux pour refaire
les enduits sur les murs et donc c'était
quand même plus agréable mieux que le
vieux ciment qui avait moins ça respire
etc
j'ai aussi fait un toit végétal donc en
fait là au moins c'est est imperméable
c'était aussi isolant et c'est quand
même plus agréable à voir que la vieille
taux qui avaient auparavant
j'ai aussi fait le mobilier sur place
buvette j'ai pas vraiment d'électricité
donc ce que je faisais en fait je
faisais vraiment un peu à l'ancienne où
j'avais ma hache je coupais l'arbre
après fallait le transporter depuis la
forêt jusqu'à la cabane donc je sois jeu
de trimballer à l'épaule l'autre enjeu
de tirs avec des sangles après il
fallait encore et corsé la brique
laplane fallait
raboter le bois il fallait faire des
entailles le ciseau à bois fer découpe à
la scie faire des trous laterrière et
donc fait j'allais aussi à faire des
bancs des chaises des tables des
étagères des lits superposés pour les
randonneurs j'ai vraiment appris à avoir
à prendre différemment de ce qu'on avait
enseigné dans le passé je faisais pas
que à prendre j'ai essayé de partager ce
que je faisais donc en fait j'avais je
filme et la vie que je menais sur place
et je m'étais après des épisodes sur
youtube et pour ceux qui se demandent
ils ont droit de se demander comment je
fais ce que je faisais parce que j'ai
aucun réseau akamai j'avais rien du tout
été isolés ma bête je marchais une
demi-heure dans l'ain dans la montagne
et après une petite demi heure de marche
y avait une station de ski qui était
fermé mais il prêtait une connexion pour
mettre en ligne les épisodes et montrer
aux gens comment ce que je faisais pour
vivre je faisais pas que appréhendées
ont partagé différemment je me
nourrissais différemment aussi parce que
le plus proche du la gta 5 heures de
marche de marche vers le vent dans la
vallée et après six heures de marche
pour remonter il fallait pas oublier le
pain est devant faisait j'avais pris des
des graines mais j'avais commencé à
faire un potager
j'avais aussi quelques poules pour faire
voir des heures faire un peu d'élevage
est donc en fait avec des bouteilles de
permaculture qui était un peu nouvelle
de l'élevage et des plantes sauvages
j'arrivais à me nourrir dans la montagne
pas non plus 100 % de ce que je voulais
tous les mois même tous les deux mois
après j'allais dans le village pour
acheter un peu de farine d'huile de
sucre par des choses que je pouvais
difficilement faire pousser en altitude
et j'ai quand même réussi à voir des
légumes parce que j'aime manger des
tomates tous les jours entre août et
septembre et ça c'était quelque chose
qui était assez cool et j'ai franchement
j'ai jaloux 20 j'y croyais pas trop au
début mais si j'avais pas essayer
j'aurais jamais su où j'avais une
alimentation qui étaient bio qui était
locale qui est plein de vitamines et
tout le contraire de ce qu'on voit dans
les sites un marché et ça encore c'est
quelque chose que nous montrent quand il
me fait croire que c'est un seul moyen
de s'alimenter
à présent il n'a plusieurs arrêts aussi
pour la consommation vous fait croire
qu'il y a différents modes enfin qu'il
ya faut toujours consommer toujours
acheter toujours rejeté
alors que non il ya peut-être d'autres
possibilités moi j'ai fait des voeux de
décroissance france t c'était un petit
peu extrême parce que vraiment je devais
aller chercher l'eau à la source si
j'avais pu cultiver mon potager je vous
dise un petit peu d'électricité pour
pouvoir m'éclairer je construisais mon
but c'est sûr que là je répare et mes
affaires et poissons si j'avais un
caleçon qui a été trouvée j'allais pas à
jeter être que c'était le seul que
j'avais là-bas donc en fait là bas j'ai
fais vraiment réussi à vivre dans la
nature à dia concerne presque rien mais
il y avait une chose qui me manquait
c'était les sciences que j'aime beaucoup
la recherche est donc en fait j'ai
contacté une équipe du cnrs à toulouse
pour faire de la recherche au plateau me
le proposait est-ce que ce que je peux
faire quelque chose de vraiment de
recherche sur la montagne et coup de bol
en fait il y avait une équipe de
géologie qui travaillaient sur le
plateau où j'étais gros mais dans ce cas
on a fait un peu de prospection en fait
de l'échantillonnage n'a fait vraiment
du terrain ensemble pour comprendre
pourquoi il y avait des plateaux qui se
former en altitude
mons terre un peu des chemises de
géomorphologie la recherche fondamentale
et ça me plaisait vraiment moins bête
j'avais réussi à vivre dans la dans la
cabane a étudié depuis la cabane à vivre
dans la nature concerné presque rien
qu'à être heureux c'est pas génial ça
mais comment ça m'a un peu deux des
trois chemins s'appelait pas forcément à
tout le monde
j'ai été rappelé par mon école qui qui
ne voulait pas que je reste ici en fait
à partir de 7 mois m'ont dit de rentrer
à lyon c'est pas ce que parce qu'ils
étaient prévus moi j'avais signé un
contrat avec eux qui me disait que je
pouvais rester un an mais je voulais
rester jusqu'à descendre passé neuf mois
là bas mais en panne quand ils m'ont
menacé même de me désinscrire de l'école
et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils m'ont
des inscrits de l'école et moi ça
c'était pas prévu voulais vraiment
rester davantage de temps et même si
après je voulais quand même un jour
revenir vers la civilisation et ben ça
ils m'ont vraiment coupé dans mon élan
ils m'ont coupé dans mon projet ça m'a
terriblement frustré de revenir si tôt à
la civilisation et découvre
revenir quand même j'ai pas pu rester
dans la cabane tout ça à cause des cours
à cause de paperasse qui étaient non
conformes à ce qu'ils voulaient mais bon
enfin un chercheur qui vit dans les bois
ça s'est jamais vu et ça ne se fera
jamais attention c'est passé c'est
interdit c'est pas ça chez vous mais du
coup c'est donc une majorité n'acceptera
pas les différents des normes de lévis
qui sont différents que ces sévices ou
être toujours considéré comme restreinte
et mise à l'écart c'est le poids de la
société qui pèsera toujours à nos yeux
et on sera toujours mis enfin on sera
toujours différent alors que justement
la différence est ce qu'il faut
rechercher
il faut penser différemment il faut
apprendre différemment il faut consommer
différemment
il faut vivre différemment moi je veux
demander en fait tu vas y si vraiment
vous quel est votre rêve qu'est ce que
vous voulez faire et même si ça ne se
fait pas faites-le osé vague récré votre
parcours qu'il soit unique et le
valoriser en temps valve a valorisé le
en tant que tel il est juste finir
l'arrestation de henry david thoreau qui
est un philosophe écrivain poète qui
s'est retiré du monde de la société au
19e siècle pour vivre dans les bois qui
est maintenant un des fondateurs de
l'écologie qui a dit je suis partie
vivre dans les bois me confronter aux
faits simples de la vie et ne pas
découvrir le jour de ma mort que je n'ai
pas vécu
merci
[Applaudissements]